[Music]
hello everyone
uh in the previous two lectures we had
been talking about
paradigm of 2d elasticity
which was plain stress and we went on to
discuss the eddy stress function
approach
and ended up at the end of those
discussions
with this bi-harmonic equation which
included within it
almost all the information conveyed by
the compatibility equation
the constitutive law and the stress
equilibrium equations
now let us see if we can do the same
sort of thing
with the other paradigm of the 2d
elasticity which is the
plane strain so we start with plane
strain
today
so just like in plain stress we started
out with a canonical
uh physical example so also here
we'll take uh uh
we'll start with a similar approach so
we considered
uh an infinitely
long uh
body which has a uniform cross section
so something like this
when i say infinitely long i basically
mean to say that it is
it is extremely long compared to its
other dimensions
so
let the cross section be of this fashion
let's see if we can join this up
going to be a little bit problematic
let's
see if we can do this better
so
so we have this sort of a situation
okay that's better now uh
what we say is that the loading on this
is taking place in a special fashion so
uh
what we basically mean is that suppose
we considered that this
is our our z-axis
this is our x-axis
and this is our y-axis
then the loading that is taking place
on the lateral uh surface of this body
that will means
this this one okay this surface not
this surface of this surface so
uh the loading that is taking place uh
it is not varying along the z direction
so it is uniform along this direction
furthermore it has no component along
the z direction
so if i have to represent it
the loading will be as a specific
example
it can be like this
i'm copy pasting the first arrow just to
give you the idea that it is perfectly
uniform
okay what cannot happen is that
we cannot have a loading which is like
this
okay which has a component along the z
direction
that cannot happen okay so that is wrong
we remove that now when we have this
kind of a situation and you understand
that this loading is going to continue
all along the length
okay so it is not just within this zone
that this loading is taking place
so when we have this kind of a situation
uh and
please note that even though i have
drawn it as an example in form of
tractions
okay applied loads here it can very well
be also in the form of a body force
and that body force also has to satisfy
this property that it cannot have any
component along the z direction and the
body force must be uniform
along the z direction so when these
conditions are satisfied
then uh what is going to happen is that
the deformation field can be taken to be
to be only a function of x and y
furthermore
the displacement along the along the z
component
that can be taken to be zero so what we
say is that
so if body forces
and tractions
our uniform along z
and do not
have any z component
then u
the displacement along the x direction
that will be a pure function of x and y
so v the displacement along the y
direction
that will be a pure function of x and y
and w is going to be zero okay so we are
not going to have
any displacement along this z direction
what this
basically means is that
we are allowed to consider
any generic slice okay we are
allowed to take any generic slice
like this
within the body and it is guaranteed
that no matter where we take the slice
along the z
the displacement field is going to be
the same in all of those slices
okay so it is somewhat reminiscent of
that thin plate like situation
so if you think of this this slice
or this how the cross-section of the
slice like the mid plane of the
of the plane stress condition it is
somewhat reminiscent of that
but there are important differences as
far as the brain fields and the stresses
are concerned
so talking about the strain fields we
can immediately
launch into a discussion of that by
noting first of all
that epsilon
xx
using the spring displacement relations
so this is going to be a pure function
of x and y
the epsilon yy similarly is going to be
a pure function
of x and y because u here is a pure
function of x and y and v is a pure
function of x and y
similarly epsilon x y
which is given by del u del y half of
del u del y plus del v del x
that is also going to be pure function
of x and y
now epsilon z z however
that is given by del w del z and since w
is zero the epsilon z is zero
furthermore epsilon zx
that is equal to half of del w
del x plus del u
del z now w
is identically zero and u is a pure
function of x and y so this term is zero
so this is zero
epsilon y z is equal to half of
del w del y plus
del v del z and here also w
is zero and the del v del z is zero
because v is a pure function of x and y
okay so what transpires is this that
unlike the plane stress condition where
the epsilon zz
was not equal to zero okay
so here it turns out that epsilon z
is zero the epsilon zx is zero and the
epsilon y z is zero
so there is a clear cut distinction with
the
plane stress condition okay so here this
is
zero that's very important important
please note this
all right now what we want to do
is proceed in a similar fashion to the
uh to the plain stress things
okay so uh first of all what we note
uh is what happens or what
simplifications
to these kinds of relations okay
the fact that epsilon z z is zero uh
among
among these uh among other among other
relations like this
so what simplification does it affect
when we talk about the
constitutive law basically the
generalized hooks law so let's consider
that in the
next page so first of all we have the
epsilon x x
that is equal to 1 by e sigma xx
minus nu sigma yy plus sigma zz
now please note that when we were
talking about the plane stress condition
we could immediately set the sigma zz to
be equal to zero
but here we are talking about the plane
strain condition in the previous page we
had not talked about
anything to do with the plane with the
stress components so right now
a priori i don't have any information to
say about the sigma zz so let us let us
keep it like it is
similarly for epsilon yy i have
1 by e sigma yy
minus nu sigma xx
plus sigma zz
again i can't say anything uh more about
this
epsilon says that however it is zero so
perhaps there is some hope here
if we set epsilon z to be equal to 0 as
seen on the first page
on the previous page then what we obtain
from here is that
sigma z said is equal to nu times
sigma xx plus sigma yy now this is
new okay this is something new uh
something fresh
and we can actually utilize this
relation
back in these two uh equations so let's
do that
okay so let's use this
here to see what we get
okay so epsilon xx is equal to
1 by e so we when you substitute the
sigma zz
with this
what we have here is sigma xx
r minus
nu sigma yy
plus nu sigma xx
plus nu sigma yy
so that is going to give me 1 by
e 1 minus
nu square sigma x x
minus nu times one plus nu
[Music]
sigma yy and from
that i can actually take out the one
plus nu
out to obtain
this
again when i use this relation
back here in the epsilon yy
what i will obtain
is
just like i have obtained the expression
for epsilon x x in terms of sigma x x
and sigma yy
i will obtain this relation
okay 1 minus nu
sigma yy minus nu
sigma xx all right
for the other terms let's see what
happens
epsilon xy is equal to 1 plus nu
by e so basically this is 1 by twice g
that is sigma x y so
you understand that because uh in the
plane strain condition
the epsilon x y in general is not zero
so
sigma x y is not going to be zero
epsilon y z however is zero
epsilon y z is zero which implies that
sigma y z
is zero so that is just like the plane
stress condition
and finally epsilon zx is also zero
and so the sigma zx
is also going to turn out to be equal to
zero
all right so sigma yz was zero in plane
stress
sigma yz is again zero in plane
sigma zx was zero in plane stress sigma
zx
is again zero in plane string
however in plane stress we had sigma z
set to be equal to zero but in plane
stream
sigma z is not zero okay so
we have some important differences
between the plane stress and the plane
strain conditions
already just by the first consideration
of the constitutive behavior
now uh if we look back at the plane
stress
uh uh formulations okay the
the mathematical framework that we
developed uh using the
under the plane strain sorry the plane
stress paradigm
uh we
what we did was to next consider the
compatibility equations
okay we motivated the entire discussion
uh surrounding the airy stress function
by considering the stress equilibrium
equations definitely
but it was only much later after we had
considered the compatibility equations
that we actually
that we actually incorporate the
information from the stress equilibrium
equations
and that is exactly the root that we
follow now so after we have considered
the compatibility equations
we are going to consider
the the after we have considered the
constitutive equations on this page we
are going to consider the
compatibility equations but you just
know for a second
that what is happening to the stress
equilibrium equations we are not going
to do anything with it
but you just know what is happening so
del sigma
xx okay so this is just like a side note
okay just to be aware of what we have
managed to do till now
let's let's take a look at the stress
equilibrium equations but
we are not going to utilize this right
now
so very quickly we'll look at it
and again we don't consider the body
force right away exactly in the fashion
that we had proceeded in the
plane stress case so you see the sigma
zx is very much zero
okay zero here so that goes away so the
first equation is very much like the
first equation that we had in the plane
stress case
from the second one we have del sigma x
y del x
plus del sigma y y del y
plus del sigma y z
del z and again you note that this term
is 0 which means
the second equation of the plane
strength plane strain
stress equilibrium equations that is
also looking exactly like the plane
stress case
but what about the third one so here we
have del sigma zx
del x plus del sigma y z
del y plus del sigma z
del z all right
now you see uh
here in this relation epsilon
xx has been expressed in terms of sigma
xx and sigma y5
epsilon yy here has been expressed in
terms of sigma yy and sigma
fine now if we if we were to revert this
equations
then we would be able to obtain
expressions of sigma
xx and sigma yy separately
in terms of epsilon xx and epsilon yy so
that is just a matter
of algebra we don't actually have to do
it we just need to note that it is
possible to find out expressions of
sigma x
x and sigma yy separately in terms of
epsilon x x and epsilon yy now the
important point that i want to drive
home
here is that individually epsilon xx and
epsilon yy
are pure functions of x and y which
means
here that sigma xx and sigma yy are also
functions of x and y
which means in turn that if we come to
this relation sigma x6 is a pure
function of x and y
sigma yy is a pure function of x and y
which means definitely that sigma z must
be a function
of x and y which means that this term
here
is going to be 0 so this is 0
this is 0 this is 0 so overall you see
that we have ended up with only these
two equations
involving the sigma x6 the sigma xy and
the sigma yy
just like as we had done in the case of
the plane stress
case okay and this is very very
interesting
and uh it gives us hope that whatever we
were able to do with the air stress
function approach
in the plane stress case we should be
able to do it in the plane string
strain case also of course there are
going to be
some differences as we'll see so
proceeding exactly like the plane stress
case what we'll do is
first consider the compatibility
equations so when we consider the
compatibility equations it will turn out
okay so it will turn out that
it is only the first of the of the
strain compatibility equations
so this one del square epsilon x x del
y square plus del square epsilon y y
del x square is equal to twice of
del square epsilon x y del x
del y that is the only equation which is
not going to turn out to be
a 0 by 0 equal to 0 form because if we
just quickly look back
at that previous page where we
considered the
compatibility equations you see
everywhere
so so for example so let us consider the
the the other equations just very
quickly okay so
uh all the terms which we deleted
based on the dependence or based on the
derivatives with respect to z
that is still very much true because
here in the plane string case also
we have the epsilon x x and epsilon y y
to be pure functions of x and y
so this term is again going to cancel
out the epsilon z now is zero
so this second equation which gave us
this thing that is again going to turn
out to be
a zero equal to zero form because
epsilon z is zero
this one also is going to give us a zero
equal to zero form
because in the plane strain condition
epsilon zz
is equal to zero note here that
uh in the plane stress case this one
turned out to be
zero primarily because of the fact
that we had y z epsilon y z
to be zero itself epsilon zx to be zero
itself which we also have in the plane
strain case
and epsilon x y was a pure function of x
and y
which is very much true here and
similarly the epsilon x x
is a pure function of x and y similarly
for
this equation also so in the plane
strain case also this is going to turn
out to be
0 equal to 0 and finally you see this
last equation
where we had the this term remaining
because of the non-zero epsilon z z but
now we do have the epsilon z to be
equal to zero in the plane strain case
so this is also going to be
equal uh turn out to be zero equal to
zero form
so these five equations they are all
going to be zero equal to zero form
only the first of the strain
compatibility equations
are is not going to be the zero equal to
zero form something substantial is
still remaining there just like the
plane stress case and this is very good
news actually
because when we proceeded from here we
neglected this equation this equation in
this equation and that was an
approximation
if you just uh rewind the video for the
for that lecture
you will see that that was i i did
mention that as an approximation
but uh as it is turning out that these
all these equations are 0 equal to 0
form
and this is the only meaningful equation
remaining
so this is no longer an approximation in
the case of the
plane string paradigm okay so let's get
back to where we were
okay so this is the only substantial
equation that we have from the
compatibility equations
and what we're going to do here is
substitute
the expressions of epsilon x x epsilon y
y and epsilon x y
using these relations okay and
we are going to do that in the next
lecture
so we have already covered uh
substantial ground
in this part of the lecture so in the
next lecture we are going to substitute
uh these these expressions in terms of
the
sigma x6 sigma yy and the sigma xy
so i'll end this part of the lecture
here thank you very much